à parler de nabila et pourtant ça match
et l'info sur nabila et dieu sait si
j'aime cette fille mais là l'info sur
nabila cette incroyable nabil a
malheureusement dû prendre un vol
commercial pour rentrer de vacances à
dubaï est là si les alors à votre avis
pour conclure je l'aï dit moi je pense
que c'est un problème de sur bagages
absolument qu'est ce qui s'est passé est
ce que des voyages énormément avec de
bons gars tout son maquillage faisait
juste ans il tout ce que tu veux à l'as
pas compris arrivée à l'aéroport dans ce
vol commercial qu'on lui ai dit vous
allez droit à 25 kg de bagages c'était
juste son maquillage finalement du coup
elle a dit comment je fais ma che
invités défilent plus précis que sahil
quelque 7500 euros de bagages ou un truc
comme ça alors éclipsé plus précis est
de racheter des valseuses et dubaï los
angeles est passé de vacances à los
angeles 2 et los angeles dubaï qu'est ce
qui s'est passé si c'est sûrement ça
nécessite bas plein plein de bagages
aussi pour les enfants et ce n'est pas
qu'une histoire de 2 alors c'est
là que gmail m mais elle a aussi ses
enfants donc non je dis la vérité elle
avait 16 malle vuitton est ce que je
désire
des effets d'enfants dans la revue
canadienne vous donner ce qu'elle avait
pas ce que c'était c'était hallucinant
elle avait 16 mâles but on a
effectivement normalement cela s'est
même pas que les blés les valises doit
pas dépasser 32 kg quand on a ce qu'on
appelle du org
précisé prendre un avion cargo et
préciser ce qu'elle n'a pas dû faire
elle a dû donc tout laissait los angeles
acheté deux trois sacs pour mettre le
nécessaire et elle a poussé un coup de
gueule et son coup de gueule c'est
celui-là ce qu'est ce qu'on l'animation
ce qu'elle a dit
vidéo mais moi la vidéo
vol commercial parce que j'avais plein
de valises
forcément je n'ai pas le choix j'ai
toutes mes valises qui faisait prendre
de kilos oubliée la rolls des 32 kg en
fait on peut avoir un plein de malice
mais il faut pas qu'elle dépasse les 32
kg du coup on a dû tout rouvrir acheter
une valise à l'aéroport pour emplir
faire des calculs là qu'est ce qui se
passe dans l'avion je dois faire un
biberon donc à mon fils j'ai pas le
petit truc le doseur je commence à
paniquer je ne sais pas quelle dose m
ensuite j'ai passé un contrôle ils
voulaient pas passer mon nous primons
d-will vous pouvez pas la prendre j'ai
dû racheter mais l ip hybride aux fins d
des aurores il m'arrive était sourd
heures les gars veulent à vie d'ayem
parce que ces jeux de daniels et son
amie elle sur par la semaine dernière
mais ça va faire réagir et
téléspectateurs chez vous je t'attends à
l'est dit cette phrase et c'est cette
phrase qui a choqué tout le monde et
peut-être était-elle en colère écoutez
moi bien plus jamais je ne prendrai de
vols d'avions normaux de vols
commerciaux donc que à chaque fois on en
est où là savoir qu'elle se déplaçait
pour des raisons professionnelles elle
devait rentrer et ce alors qu'elle a des
enfants c'est son train de dix noms mais
on peut pas tout mettre
elle vit
avec certains moyens qu'ils sortent un
pardon et c'est proportionnel à ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle gagne c'est son
mode de vie elle avait tous ces enfants
et 6 alors que lorsqu'il sonné ier
mayenne
desiro mais dire aux gens me dire à des
gens ont faim comme à l action mais est
ce qu'on sait pourquoi ce coup ciel n'a
pas pris de jets puisque d'habitude à la
le jet la lave est trop balises pourquoi
l'a pas fait c'est une bonne question
parce qu'elle permet de chasser c'est
indisponible et charisma il faut prendre
un gros gros jam je rêve que peut-être
c'était trop coûteux
mais peu importe nabila avant d'être
nabila prenez des vols commerciaux comme
tout le monde elle savait que son âge
alors qu'hugo élise le problème c'est
qu'en fait le fond de l'histoire c'est
bidon c'est à dire qu'à un moment t'es
pas organisé t'es pas capable de 30
compte que sur un vol commercial il ya
des règles de sécurité de tous nous il
ya des règles on le reçoit même quand on
prend les billets oui malheureusement
elle s'en est pas rendu compte ça fait
chier et comme à 5 à dole mais non mais
j'ai envie de dire c'est de la faute de
qui bah c'est de la faute de personne en
tout cas si la faute de quelqu'un c'est
un ami luiz à alors moi je pense que
l'herbe on l'a perdu honnêtement parce
que c'est une fille qui avait quand même
les pieds ancrés dans la réalité parfois
moi je les adore je n'aime vraiment
beaucoup mais là c'est inadmissible
c'est pas le fait qu'elle le fasse ou
même qu'elle réagisse mal c'est qu'elle
juge opportun de se filmer en train de
dire ça comme si jamais les architectes
un ring
mais tu as raison
attendrait canadien a réussi un problème
on aime aussi nabila parce qu'elles
partagent tout et qu elle triche
première partie c'est ce que j'aime bien
le message et mathieu alors tu sais ce
que j'allais dire je vais dans le sens
d'ayem et je suis pas totalement
d'accord avec isa parce qu'en fait la
bilal est suffisamment intelligente en
faisant ça pour savoir qu'il ya du
deuxième et du troisième degré et que
les gens qui la suivent vous aussi sont
amusés voilà ils vont pas avec eux
dans l'air qui est marrant qui est pas
forcément à prendre au premier degré
mais florian
jean-jacques l'âge at-elle aujourd'hui
elle a 35 ans bref voilà quand tu sais
qu'il est franchement je chope est
démago co2 c'est qu'un français sur deux
qui partent pas en vacances ya 22 ans et
drôle à 3,5 c'est m non c'est pas des
ragots mais pas démago j'aurai un jet je
le prends sa pouliche de francs je vous
dis franchement et mauvais choix pas une
vidéo style à deux heures de retard mon
geste ps tu vas non je dirai rien le
caviar ma gueule ou quoi tu crois que
j'ai rien post ltd
[Applaudissements]